For the grace of God offers salvation
to all people teaching us
to live Godly life.
Jesus gave himself for us to redeem us and to
purify for himself a people that
are his very own.
Well, happy Sunday to you Faith Family. It is
a joy to worship together with you every Sunday our
King and Savior Jesus Christ. He's worthy of
it all whether it's whether it's quiet and smaller
and simple last week or big
and joyful and and overwhelming in
some sense this week. We see that he is worthy and
he is being worshiped.
I'm a little sad today though, because as you can tell we've come
to the end of our journey through the book of
Titus.
This new testament letter from Paul to Titus and I've
come to love it. I hope you have too and the God's worked in it
and through it in your life.
Maybe you're new here. And you don't know anything about Titus. That's okay because we
are going to walk through a brief summary to catch
us up on those things. But first of all, I'm thankful that you
are here with us. If if you are new we haven't met you
yet. Please introduce yourself to us if you can or there's a QR code
in the seat back. We're not gonna spam you but we do want to help you
walk towards Jesus. That's the goal in everything we
do here.
But this letter to Titus remember that the melodic line
that we have seen that the tune
it has consistently played throughout the whole
book. Is this idea that that both the church as
well as individual Believers are gods.
And the way we've said that is that we are his very own.
The church is and we are his very own as
Titus 214 says clearly that Jesus gave
himself for us to redeem us from all lawlessness and
to purify for himself a people for
his own possession.
Who are zealous for good works?
And what we've seen is that since we are his we must Orient our
church as well as our own lives around
what he says.
in his word
That's what Paul was doing with Titus here. He's using
this personal letter to instruct Titus
on how important character was for leaders, for example, but
also important character was for believers individually as
the the world would see a picture of Jesus through them.
And so we we see him encourage things,
but he also warned Titus about false teachers
people who are creeping in and trying to say
that it was salvation through Jesus. Yes, but also
Jesus plus works.
Adding layers on top of it. That's why Paul threw
out the book repeatedly clarified the
gospel.
This glorious good news of jesus' Life Death and Resurrection in
our place our treasure that we hold that
it transforms everything. He kept coming back to the
gospel including what that gospel does is it
makes us pure makes us excited as you saw in
214 to do good works.
the gospel moves us
but it also does give us Grace.
and Power
to change even when we drift into
sin at times.
So here's how we get some all of that up.
We're called to live different transformed lives in
light of this message.
So here's how we might summarize it in
all of this.
Since we are his since we are God's
we ought to be devoted?
right the whole point since we are his
we ought to be devoted.
The summary we're going to see today in this benediction of Paul's
letter to Titus. So if you're not already there
take your copy of God's word turn with me for the final time in
this series to Titus.
Titus Chapter 3 verses 12 through 15
As you're turning there, I must confess that it's hard to preach the end
of any of these letters in the New Testament.
Because it's a struggle because there's really very little structure in any
of them. It's it's like, you know, just saying hi to people
hey Titus tell hi to this
person or or Timothy says hi, you know
those kind of things it's like we're what do you do with that? It's just a bunch of greetings.
Well, you'll see I think it's still fruitful and so look
at it with me. Try to see it though through titus's eyes
as he would receive this letter.
Even the church reading it later. How would they have received this?
verses 12 through 15
When I send Artemis or tickacus to you do your best
to come to me at nicopolis for I've decided
to spend the winter there?
And do your best to be speed zenos the
lawyer and Apollos on their way see that they lack
nothing.
And let our people learn to devote themselves to Good Works.
So as to help cases of urgent need and not
be unfruitful.
All who are with me send greetings to you.
And greet those who love us in the faith.
Grace be with you all.
God we need you to to show us what you want us
to see here.
How you want to change us? So give us
soft Hearts good soil in our hearts
to receive the planted word here and
and bear good fruit as you want us to
so Holy Spirit you have to do that work today.
We submit to you in that in jesus'
Authority. Amen.
So again, since the whole theme of this letter has been this idea of of
his very own that we are his very own. That
means as I've said we ought to be devoted to him in light
of that set apart for him submitted to
him. We might say
Okay, so in what ways?
How should we be devoted? Well first from
the passage in response to being his we ought to be devoted
to community.
That's one thing we learn here is that we ought to be devoted to
community. Now when we say community, we don't mean like the city
in which you live or the neighborhood. We're not saying that we're talking about Christian relationships.
Now, we're communities often used for that
Christian relationships. Could you did you see
the intimacy of all of these people that
Paul is talking about with Titus?
Paul somewhere else on mission for the Lord Faithfully serving
and he names these four men as co-laborers in
the ministry.
Two of them. We don't know much about.
But Apollos and tickacus they're mentioned
in the book of Acts multiple times and multiple letters
in the New Testament that Paul mentions them
as proven faithful workers.
So he's identifying them and calling them
out and you had these four Ministry leaders that Paul sent
to Crete probably carrying
this letter to Titus in some way and and they
were it seems like sent to relieve Titus to
be able to to visit Paul and take over the work. Well
Paul is needing Titus to visit the you see
how this is all working out. But then but notice did you see there's also this
unknown group who's with Paul?
There's a group that greeted Titus as well all
who are with me send greetings to you. And so
what you're seeing here, even with Unknown People
is this broad network of people throughout the
early church history.
Like you see this gift of community that they had.
They're serving together. They were spending time together. You
see this community.
By the way, I don't say this enough, but it is an honor
to be a part of this network of Believers this
church this Faith Family.
It really is an honor for me to be here and serve
with you and serve especially with the staff team that
we have that I get to Champion all over we had an event
with other churches involved just a couple weeks ago
here and and I got to kind of just bask in
what people were saying about our staff team and I
just get to Champion and say how great they are and it's sweet to watch other
people affirm that and so thank you church for being
awesome first of all, but then also for
for your faithfulness through a lot of hard things over the
last few years.
And thank you for the gift of community that
we have here. It's a sweet thing. If you're
new, I hope you can kind of taste that even in just the
short time. You've been here.
But you see evidence of that here in Crete, don't you?
This this gift of community is what
Paul said in verse 15 greet those who love us in the
faith.
Remember that Paul likely planted many of these churches because
he spent a few months Shipwrecked on the island of Crete. He
probably planted. So he you can imagine that they
would have gotten extremely close as they spent a
ton of time together enjoying deep Community with
one another they're growing and their faith together. They're defending against
these Pagan religions all over the island. They're growing
as they spent time together that would
Bond them wouldn't it?
and remember
these were not blood relatives.
In fact, many of these people weren't even Jewish they were of Gentile
background.
Yet they had a deep the word here
is agape. Love for one another.
Why?
because of the shared faith
because of this common salvation that they
had
so here's what that means.
You can actually be closer with your
spiritual family. Then you
may be with your biological family.
Now hopefully those link up hopefully your biological family is
also your spiritual family. You can walk together and that's a sweet blessing.
But I know in this room it's often. Not that.
Sometimes it plays out more like Jesus said
would happen in households because of faith
in him.
Jesus says that this way in Luke 12:53.
He says this at his coming they will be
divided.
Father against son and son against mother mother against
daughter a daughter against mother mother in
law against her daughter-in-law and daughter-in-law against
mother-in-law.
now I know some of you're sitting there thinking like I got no problem being divided from
my mother-in-law right you're saying that
that's not what we're talking about here. Okay.
by the way, there's probably some room for you to repent in that that attitude
but
But but listen, this is what we're talking about with this.
When your pursuit of Jesus?
Means you must choose at some
point who you're going to listen to and follow.
Right. That's what this is saying. Are you going to follow
the ways and the teachings and the the instructions of
your family or you're going to follow Jesus?
Hopefully you don't have to make that decision. Hopefully that's ideal
that you don't but the reality is so many of
you have had to do that.
And I get the pain involved in that that's one of
the hardest decisions you will ever have to make.
I mean, there's nothing like being abandoned by those who are closest to
you. Simply for what you believe.
But that's why one of my favorite passages in scripture
is it's actually a New Living Translation Psalm 68
verse 6. It says that God places the
lonely in families.
It's a lot of applications to that but God provides a
new family a faith family.
So what Jesus said in Matthew 12, he's talking about
true family here. He's speaking to the people and he
says his mother and his brothers or somebody comes
to him and says your mother and your brothers are standing outside asking to speak
with you and Jesus replied to the man who
told him who is my mother who are my brothers?
So it's biological families outside and they say hey they want
to talk to you and he's like who who is that and stretching out
his hand toward his disciples. He said here are my
mother and my brothers.
For whoever does the will of my Father in
Heaven is my brother and sister and mother.
See, that's the point here.
You saw back in Crete how close these
Believers were?
That's Paul said to greet those
who were there who love us in the faith.
You know why they loved each other so much so deeply.
Because they had no one else.
Right there, they'd lost the whole situation they'd
lived in their family had thought they
were crazy the World cast them out from everything. They
lost their jobs. They were threatened in physical
harm. They had to move location. They had
lost everything and so they truly were
family.
Truly were family and it was
deep and it was rich not just because they shared interests or
they shared Hobbies or their kids were the same age. They had this
because of the Gospel.
because of the Gospel
it's the picture we get from acts 4 the
the first church who was experiencing intense persecution
listen to this.
The full number of those who believed were of
one heart and soul.
No one said that any of the things that belonged to him was his
own but they had everything in common and with
great power the apostles were giving testimony to
the resurrection of the Lord Jesus and great grace was
upon them all and check this out. There was
not a needy person among them.
Who Do You Love Like That
Do you have any believers in your life?
That you would call family like that.
Or like a few of us in our community group that that have commanded
together as a little smaller group of
that. We call ourselves family.
Friends like family, right?
But the point is that this is people that
you would do anything for
Any time of the day?
People who love you not because you can do anything for them,
but people who love you just because of the Gospel.
And they're willing to say I'm going to sacrifice my life for
you.
Like that's what we see in Crete.
Because that's all they had.
Let me clear though.
You cannot find that.
merely sitting in these rows once a
week
You also can't find that with 1500 people.
Right this this idea of community you
need it.
You need these kind of Christian loving relationships similar
to what they had in Acts chapter 4 you need
to be devoted to community. Now the way
that looks here Community groups of 12 to 20ish people. Well,
you know people a little more deeply but even further than
that, we have what we call Micro groups which are groups of three to
five men with men women with women where you
are really known by
people.
You're sacrificing and you're serving one another where
you know someone so well.
Even somebody who's so different than you.
That you still look across the table from them and
you say I love you.
I'll do anything for you.
That's what they had.
In Crete and I get it putting yourself out. There is a
risk.
You have to take a step of faith.
But compelling love is one of our churches values.
And what that says is that we demonstrate the love of Jesus by respecting
the Dignity of every person sacrificing for
our neighbors and cultivating Unity with our faith family.
Like that's a safe place for anybody, right?
Doesn't mean we're okay with sin. It means we're going to walk with you out of
sin.
And we're gonna love you.
So since you are his
be devoted to community.
Second though.
Be devoted to Ministry.
Be devoted to community and be devoted to Ministry
because we are his be devoted to
Ministry.
Titus 3 look at verses 13 to 14 again
do your best meaning do as much as you can to speed
Zenith the lawyer and Apollos on their way see that
they lack nothing.
And let our people learn to devote themselves to good works. So as
to help cases of urgent need and not be unfruitful.
Now there are two aspects of ministry. I want you to see here.
First there's the external aspect the
the outside the walls of the church part of
what he just said you find in verse 13, right Zenus and
Apollos were apparently only there in Crete for
a short time.
They were continuing their Trek to a new mission location that coming
through Crete. And so Paul says.
Here's what you do now. Now we could think of that today as people that we've
sent to the field that they might come back through for a
little bit or or church planting teams that we send out or even
workers that we've sent out locally to other churches or
to other environments of service out there
or even our church staff might be included in this you see
these are short kind of mission driven entities.
So what Titus is to do?
Was to lead the churches on Crete to band
together to ensure that these two agents of God's
Mission were provided for adequately.
Right. They were it says put their best effort forward to
see that Zenus and Apollos had
maybe new clothes if they needed them a ride to
the port on your donkey or or maybe lodging somewhere or
hey, you can use my ship. If you need to go to Greece
you go that way here's where I'm going or maybe just money
for the trip. We don't know what it was. All we know
is the churches were to recognize that they had
been blessed by God.
To be a blessing to others.
That it wasn't just for their own Comfort. They were to see this.
as a part of their Ministry
even outside even far beyond anything that would affect them
in Crete.
Listen, is that not what we're about here?
Like when we talk about our mission of equipping one another to love
Jesus and live since
That includes even as a church, we're living
scent in a sense where we're out
there doing things. We can't do ourselves. That's
why we're retooling our staff and we're retooling Ministries
around this idea of planting and replanting
churches sending missionaries. We're focusing
on that because we realize the kingdom is
bigger than Henderson Hills.
And there's people out there and there's mission that God
has for us. That's why we're willing.
to send 40 key church members
to a struggling Church near downtown, Oklahoma
City
To help Revitalize and replant that church so that
there's a gospel influence there that we could never reach from here.
And listen, I get it.
As I stood up here with Brett and we stood up here
as the whole team as I stood there and I said it that there's attention between
the desire for community and the desire
for Mission Ministry.
Like it was hard to send those ones
that we love.
Where we won't see him very often.
And they're moving over there. And and we we have that struggle
the internal tension of that but hear me.
We cannot you cannot be so devoted
to community that You Hinder the
mission.
Right you see this?
That you're not willing to multiply for the kingdom of God.
Kind of this us for no more. We're gonna keep everybody here and
we can't multiply.
We have to be willing to say all right, we're sending
40 of our best to go.
Let me press this maybe a little more.
Close to home for you.
We're out of space.
For any new CGS to start at 9:00 am.
On campus any building we've put people in closets like
we're trying to find anything.
And I know you're in here. So your seat you don't meet right
now I get that.
But how can you facilitate this idea of
Shifting so that other people can grow?
Like even thinking how can we send some of
our best to reach new people in New groups and
start home groups and start Sunday evening groups and start finding ways
and Wednesday nights to find people that are
that are wanting Community, but they don't have anywhere to be
no anybody. They can't connect yet.
How can you be preparing your group to say well what if some of
us are going to go plant the next Church?
How can you be thinking that way now and begin practicing what
it looks like to live a life of ministry as
a church?
I know it's hard.
But don't be so devoted to to community that we
miss the mission.
So yes that includes sending that
includes supporting praying then a sports encourages people
to go and setting aside
comfort so that new work can happen. It also includes giving financially that
that God's work can spread even further all over the world. That's
all part of what we can do as a church.
To further the ministry that God has just like they
did with Zenus and Apollos on Crete.
But there's also an aspect of ministry that I want you to see here.
That gets a little bit more individual a little
more daily.
Verse 14 illustrates this that we are to devote ourselves to
good works. So as to help cases of urgent
need and not be unfruitful.
That's obviously through zenos an Apollos. But but that applies so
much bigger, doesn't it?
It's what the whole book of Titus has said repeatedly be
devoted to Good Works. Be ready be zealous for
good works.
And that's not just character. Like we saw in chapter
3 verse 1. It's not just that it's also here
cases of urgent need.
How would we translate that? We would say anything that the Lord
puts right in front of you to do.
When you look around when you watch something or you see something it's
an urgent need. That's what God has put
in front of you.
That's a good work for you to do.
now remember
a distracted believer will often
miss those spirit-led moments.
You're not looking for you're just kind of walking through life wandering through life.
You won't see that but a devoted believer.
Will be looking for those things will see those
opportunities that God is putting right in front of
them because that's what God is recreated us to do right Ephesians 2:10.
He's recreate you to do good
works. He's prepared those for you to
do which means they're out there which means all you not need to
start doing is start looking for them and start living them out.
Your daily Ministry.
That's how your fruitful in your life.
He's given you gifts. He's giving you opportunities and resources puts
things right in front of you for you to use those things
in that Ministry.
so you don't think
that Ministry is just doing what I'm doing right now or or
music or teaching kids or whatever else
don't think that's Ministry because what that does is it severely
limits what God wants to do through his body in
the world.
Now he has a Ministry for you believer every single
day.
At home in your workplace all of like he
has a Ministry for you. So what you do is you abide
in him to see it and then
to be fruitful in it as you live out his
design.
Jesus said it this way in John 15 4
and 5. He says abide in me, and I and you
as the branch cannot bear fruit by itself, unless it
abides in the vine. Neither. Can you unless you
abide in me?
I am the vine you are the branches whoever abides in
me and I in him he it is that bears much fruit for
apart from me. You can do nothing.
And he continues in verse 8 by this. My father is glorified that
you bear much fruit. And so prove to
be my disciples.
Right. You see this? It's a public manifestation of
God's work through you good works are meant
to shine. Brightly on God.
As you do those things, so be devoted
to Ministry.
Just watch where God is at work around the world
and join a minute.
Pray actively support give go
right that you do that through the
church. Absolutely, but also be devoted to
the Daily Ministry God has for you wherever you
are, whatever you are doing, whatever situation you're in look
for God's Ministry through you.
at school
where you can be a light.
Loving others. Radically that can be your mission field
is your school. What does God want to do
through you tomorrow at school?
Maybe it's an assisted living home or a hospital for you
and you're devoted to good works with those doctors and nurses
and fellow residents that God puts in your
life.
Your neighborhood your workplace your home look for the pressing needs
that God puts right in front of your face and
go for it.
This is not complicated.
He just does.
Through you what he wants to love those people.
In those ways. I mean just think of how the
world would see something very different.
As we devote ourselves to Good Works.
As God produces good fruit through US think
of what the world would begin to see.
We really believe this.
And we've been changed by it.
But there's one more critical phrase in this letter.
from Paul to Titus and
the very end of verse 15 very last line
of the letter.
But it's actually the way Paul started the letter as well.
This is chapter one verse 4.
To Titus my true child in a
common Faith Grace and peace from God the
father and Christ Jesus our savior.
So that's how he started it. But then now look
at how he finished it. It says Grace be with
you all.
Now, why would Paul essentially repeat himself?
Like did he forget that he wrote at the beginning?
Like the first line he forgot that no, of course, he didn't.
I think he did it because it's so important.
Because this is so important see
it would have been really easy for Titus or
the church to read this letter and be
overwhelmed and be intimidated or discouraged
and we can never do that.
Like Titus might have looked at the commands here to be
a man full of the spirit full of self-control
sound faith. That is this
what you need to be Titus or to be a leader. You need to be upright. You
need to be holy feel handle the word against the opposition and
Titus might have thrown his hands up and said
I'm out.
There's no way I can do who can ever match up to that Paul.
That's why Paul bookended this
letter with the great grace of God
in Jesus.
That's why Paul said what he said in chapter 3 verses 3
through 5. He says for we ourselves were once
foolish disobedient LED astray slaves
to various passions and Pleasures passing our
days and Malice and envy hated by others hating
one another timid. Hey Titus, this is the
way you are as an unbeliever. It's the way you once
were Titus but
When the goodness and loving kindness of God our savior appeared
he saved us not because of Works
done by us and righteousness.
But according to his own Mercy by the washing of
regeneration and renewal of the Holy
Spirit.
That's why Paul wrote These cherished words
in Chapter 2 verses 11 through 14. He says
the grace of God has appeared bringing salvation
for all people training us to renounce
ungodliness and worldly passions training us
to live self-control upright Godly lives in the present
age where we're waiting for our blessed. Hope
the appearing of the glory of our great God and Savior Jesus Christ who
gave himself for us to redeem
us from all lawlessness to purify for
himself a people for his own possession who are zealous for
good works. He kept coming back to the
gospel to remind Titus that God's
grace is the foundation of all of this.
See the point of the entire letter again. We are his own
we are gods.
And that is the only source to do
any of the rest of the what the letter actually says.
So hear me, please do not walk away.
from today from this whole book of Titus
with a longer list of rules to follow or commands to obey and
you feel this weight creeping up on your shoulders. No,
the one thing you should remember from this.
Is that since we are his since we
are his we must be devoted first and foremost to
Jesus.
Don't be devoted to these things that you need to do be devoted
first and foremost to Jesus.
Here's why that's critical.
because
the only way you can obey
the rest of it is by him empowering you.
The only way you're going to want to obey the
rest of this is through remembering all that he's
done for you.
The only way you will long for Community. The
only way you are long for and commit to Ministry is
by seeing how those things will draw you to him
even more.
You've got to be devoted to Jesus first because
this and I've said this before throughout the series it always must
start with being overdoing.
Being over doing you
have to remember who you are first Christian.
Before you can ever hope to properly attempt to
live for him.
Don't leave the gospel and then start trying it in
your own effort as soon as you move past your identity in
Christ.
You drift into Pride.
As maybe you do get it right for a little while and
you start to feel pretty good about yourself.
Or you drift into despair?
when you blow it again and again
Once you move past your identity in Christ you lay in
to one of those two things. That's why
we must keep the gospel beating loudly in
our hearts.
because what happens
That's we remember jesus' life death and Resurrection. As we
remember that cry of Jesus of
it is finished as we remember those things what
that then turns good works into is a
celebratory dance rather than slavishly trying
to earn our salvation.
It's like we get to do this.
We get to follow I get to work in this
we get to serve in that we get to do these things
for people on the other side of we get to do this now.
Remember the gospel.
And live in light of all that he's done
for you.